it is now the Republicans move and the
impeachment stalemate in the Senate
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
met with Democratic leader Chuck Schumer
but says they are still at an impasse on
how to proceed with an impeachment trial
expected next month Congress is out for
the holiday recess and the president is
in Florida as we mentioned for the next
two weeks chip Reid is in West Palm
Beach with the latest developments this
morning chip good morning
well good morning president Trump
arrived here in Florida late last night
leaving behind a bitterly divided
Congress following his impeachment
speaker Pelosi has not yet sent those
articles of impeachment from the house
to the Senate where the trial is
expected to occur because the leaders in
the Senate just can't agree on how to
proceed prior to boarding Air Force One
last night President Trump signed the
twenty20 defense authorization bill in a
hangar at Joint Base Andrews before
several hundred military personnel the
law I'm signing today provides 738
billion that's with a be seven hundred
and thirty eight billion dollars in
defense funding for the 2020 that's an
all-time record in the history of our
country earlier in the day senior White
House advisors visited Capitol Hill for
a tour of the Senate floor where the
impeachment trial will take place we
remain at an impasse on these logistics
but Senate leaders Mitch McConnell and
Chuck Schumer have yet to agree on how
the Senate trial would proceed
I told Leader McConnell that we would
not support any trial without witnesses
and documents and House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi said that before she sends the
articles of impeachment to the Senate
she wants to know details on witnesses
and procedures we would hope there would
be a fair process just as we hope that
they would honor the Constitution
meanwhile Christianity today a magazine
popular with evangelical Christians a
key part of the president's base called
for his removal from office writing in
an editorial none of the president's
positives can balance the moral and
political danger we face under a leader
of such gross
the moral character the president lashed
out at the magazine in a series of
tweets calling it far left and adding no
president has done more for the
evangelical community yesterday the
president accepted speaker Pelosi's
invitation to give the annual State of
the Union address on February 4th
incredibly that came just two days after
Pelosi oversaw the president's
impeachment Jeff all right chip thank
you very much
you